[Music]
on this friday night disturbing new
accusations
the former soldier seeking help who now
says he felt a veterans affairs worker
pressured him to consider medically
assisted death fringe groups gaining
momentum in canada a lot of people have
gotten conspiracy brain it's hard to
turn off moving to clear the backlog the
solutions on route to canadian airports
and 80 years since the disaster at diap
there's a sting to it to diep that will
canadians will never get past
reflections on one of canada's worst
wartime failures
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
good evening and thank you for joining
us disturbing new details are emerging
about a controversial call between a
former canadian soldier and a worker at
veterans affairs canada global news has
now spoken directly with the vet who
were not naming to protect his privacy
he says a medically assisted death was
pushed on him as he tried to get
treatment for post-traumatic stress now
veterans affairs is not allowed to
provide resources for medically assisted
dying tonight the former soldier is
joining calls to push the government to
take action over this shocking
suggestion our mercedes stevenson has
tonight's top story and before that a
warning some of the details may be
triggering for some
he served canada on the front lines and
suffered serious injuries that have
haunted him and at times nearly cost him
his life
but it was all finally turning around
the canadian veteran was ready to begin
treatment at a clinic for a traumatic
brain injury and felt he was on the
upswing
until he says the person who was
supposed to be helping him get better
from veterans affairs suggested that he
could consider a medically assisted
death the veteran told global news that
the vac service agent didn't leave it at
a single mention but brought it up
multiple times on the call including
after he had said he was uncomfortable
and did not consider that an option the
veteran said he felt quote pressured and
that he was shocked and disgusted by the
call and his family felt physically sick
the veteran says he was alarmed by the
persistence of the agent and worried
others may have had a similar experience
he says he asked has anyone else done
this the veteran says the agent said she
had helped another veteran who chose
maid
is he dead the veteran says he asked the
veteran told global news she said yes
and that medically assisted death was
quote better than having him blow his
brains all over the wall or driving his
car into something
the veteran says the employee then told
him if he ever changed his mind and
wanted to access medically assisted
death he should call her and she would
help him connect to resources
after the veteran terminated the call he
immediately launched a series of written
and phone complaints to vac warning them
about what she had said frankly it
stinks of a cover up the story has
outraged the veteran community
shock outrage anger very angry we've
been
working tirelessly about trying to
prevent suicides for the entire time
that i've been a veteran advocate bruce
moncour was shot in the head on
operation medusa in afghanistan he also
suffers from ptsd and a traumatic brain
injury i had to relearn how to read
write walk talk he believes the phone
call underlines major problems at
veterans affairs and wants immediate
action including committee hearings on
parliament hill to get to the bottom of
what happened i think the minister has
had a
has probably been one of the worst
ministers of my lifetime
that i can remember the minister has
been unavailable for an interview with
global news every time we've asked this
week but tonight his office made an
announcement just before we went to air
putting out a statement saying that
minister mccauley has directed the top
bureaucrat at veterans affairs to quote
undertake a full and thorough
investigation into this matter and that
they will now be ensuring that all front
line workers receive training direction
and formal advice on how to deal with
questions around medical assistance and
death as for vac they say they can't
corroborate the statements made by the
veteran in his call with us today but
they are investigating the matter they
also say there's no recording of the
call in question and they won't comment
on whether or not the person behind it
is still working for veterans affairs
farah mercedes stephenson in calgary
thank you mercedes
there are signs tonight canada's
airlines and airports are now being
better equipped to handle the increased
travel demand as you may have
experienced firsthand the last few
months have been frustrating for many
travelers and today the country's
transport minister blamed the problems
on the pandemic but as town vernon
explains the opposition says it's the
federal government who should shoulder
much of the blame
for anyone boarding an airplane this
summer it's been a case of hope for the
best
but prepare for the worst whatever was
in our checked luggage we just decided
if we never saw it again
we were okay with that canadian airports
have been plagued with problems all
summer from long lines to canceled
flights and lost luggage when you've had
people that have been forced to
cocoon and stay at home for two years
everybody's dying to travel everybody's
dying to go on vacation according to
ottawa daily passenger traffic at
canada's airports has jumped more than
250 since the start of the year and the
simple fact is airports and airlines
have not been able to handle the demand
i think that it's not the sort of thing
that you want to
have as the talk of the town when it
comes to the global travel industry
we know that pearson and montreal have
been ranked number one and number two of
worst airports in the world that is an
international embarrassment the
conservatives say much of the blame
lands on the federal liberal government
including its much-maligned arrive can
app for international arrivals it's had
no shortage of problems from glitches
ordering vaccinated canadians into
quarantine to privacy concerns why is
the government not abandoning the
mandatory use of arrived can and why are
you instead making it permanent a ride
can is not contributing to the
congestion in fact a rift can is a
useful tool that helps verify the
vaccination status of an individual
before arriving at our borders the
transportation minister says the
government is taking other steps
including hiring more than 700 new
officers to speed up security lines he
says nearly 90 percent of passengers
departing from the nation's four largest
airports last week got through within 15
minutes we are seeing encouraging
results but there's still more work to
be done
for these travelers the trip out of
montreal was smooth sailing no issues uh
we were early
and now we're just waiting for our
baggage so fingers crossed it arrives
like i said hope for the best
plan for the worst
tom vernon global news edmonton
a water shortage in iqaluit has prompted
the nunavut government to declare a
state of emergency
a lack of precipitation has dropped the
water level in the apex river to a
40-year low that river flows into the
city's reservoir lake geraldine and it
won't be fully replenished before freeze
up the state of emergency is meant to
speed up regulatory approvals to allow
for water from another lake to be pumped
in the system
just in time for the start of the school
year health canada has approved a coven
19 booster dose for children aged 5 to
11. the pfizer 10 microgram vaccine is
the first booster to be approved for
that age group the national advisory
committee on immunization says it can be
given to kids at least six months after
their first two doses the vaccination
rate for kids aged five to 11 is the
lowest of any cohort with only about 42
percent having received two doses
covered 19 prevention strategies
including maintaining up-to-date
vaccination remains the foundation of
our protection individually and
collectively canada's chief public
health officer says vaccine campaigns
should start to ramp up to get boosters
to all canadians ahead of an expected
fall covered surge more than 82 percent
of canadians have completed a primary
series of vaccines but just under 50
percent have received their first
booster 12 percent have received four
doses
one impact if the so-called freedom
convoy that occupied ottawa was seeing
alt-right groups and their conspiracy
theories out of the shadows while most
of the pandemic-related mandates and
lockdowns are now in the past those same
people who linked anti-vaccine and
anti-government beliefs haven't gone
away as mike trolley reports
confrontations in two ontario cities
this week are putting them back in the
spotlight
for 130 years st bridget's catholic
church has stood peacefully a stone's
throw from parliament hill in ottawa's
lower town district that piece it
appears has been disturbed it doesn't
matter if they pay today or not they're
out
they got to go not long after a bailiff
issued an eviction notice to the tenants
dina sharif showed up to make a point
about hypocrisy freedom for me but not
freedom for thee you see the current
occupants are members of a group that
call themselves the united people of
canada or tupac with a stated yet
somewhat vague goal of building
community we are called to bring healing
to the nation
[Music]
some of those apparently leading tupac
have links to the so-called freedom
convoy that occupied parts of ottawa
earlier this year although director
diane nolan now dismisses that as an
event and wants people to be less
critical and judgmental they see the
church as a home base residents see it
as a headache that's bound to get worse
once you establish the headquarters and
once you have um
once once you have more trucks coming
and whatnot how bad does it get does it
become a staging area for future convoy
occupations we don't know
just last weekend followers of the
self-professed queen of canada romana
dillo showed up in peterborough ontario
to arrest the city's police force it
didn't go as planned there's no direct
connection between ditalo's followers
and tupac yet evan balgord of the
anti-hate network says canadians should
take note because both groups espouse
the same disdain for canadian law so
there's this whole pseudo law movement
it's been around for a very long time
and it has different bases but basically
the premise of it is what we all agree
are laws and are codified and enforced
aren't real
uh and in fact it's their alternative
legal system that's real and they think
if they use certain language that it's
like magic and they can get out of
responsibility for things it may sound
delusional but balgord says the number
of conspiracy theory believers in canada
is on the rise and tupac for one may
present as a fringe group but they're
also growing in numbers
mike drewlay global news
a major milestone tonight for canada's
top court justice michelle obama has
been appointed to the supreme court of
canada making her the first indigenous
person to sit on the highest bench in
the country
aubameyang has spent the last five years
as a judge at the ontario superior court
of justice she was the first indigenous
woman to hold that position she is an
abenaki member of the odinak first
nation in quebec she's bilingual having
grown up in a small francophone
community in northern ontario bonsawen
will fill the vacancy left by justice
michael moldaver who is set to retire
next month
liquor sales are now being rationed at
government-owned outlets in british
columbia the move comes in response to
ongoing job action from one of bc's
biggest public sector unions
all customers including bars and
restaurants can purchase a maximum of
three bottles of any booze or wine beer
is not included in the rationing on
monday the bc general employees union
set up picket lines outside four liquor
distribution warehouses the union is
looking for wage increases that keep
pace with inflation
pointing fingers and provocations
coming up the fears of a looming nuclear
disaster in ukraine plus coffee cat
coffee it looks like starbucks it smells
like starbucks but
it's not starbucks
russian officials say an investigation
is underway into the cause of a fire in
an ammunition storage depot that led to
the evacuation of two villages near the
ukrainian border
[Music]
blast erupted overnight from the
facility near the border city of
belgorod no casualties have been
reported and this is the latest in a
string of explosions behind russian
lines in ukraine continued russian
shelling in the northern city of kharkiv
has left at least 18 people dead the
fresh attacks which began on wednesday
mark one of the deadliest stretches in
ukraine's second largest city since the
war began
rhetoric over europe's largest nuclear
power plant continues to ramp up ukraine
claims russia wants to disconnect the
zaparisha plant from its electricity
grid while russian president vladimir
putin warns of a large-scale catastrophe
if the shelling continues in the region
as redmond shannon reports the
international community is attempting to
intervene to avoid a major nuclear
accident
this footage appears to show the inside
of zaparisia nuclear power plant those
are thought to be russian military
vehicles europe's largest nuclear power
station has been under russian control
now for more than five months in recent
weeks reports of shelling around it have
increased and so have the accusations
both sides in the war say the other is
to blame and planning further incidents
to provoke conflict in odessa un
secretary general antonio guterres
repeated calls for russia to withdraw
from the facility if we demilitarize as
we propose
the plant the problem will be solved
ukraine claims russia wants to
disconnect the plant from the grid the
electricity from zaporizia is ukrainian
electricity
and it's necessary especially during the
winter for the ukrainian people and
these
principle must be fully respected
nuclear power constitutes a fairly
substantial fraction of ukraine's power
availability and so this is definitely
going to affect electricity supplies
within the country and that might well
have been part of russia's plans in
taking over japanese nuclear physicist
mv ramana says that while a missile
strike triggering an incident with a
reactor or spent fuel may seem unlikely
it's not impossible a further concern is
stress on staff effectively working at
gunpoint since march the possibility of
error is quite high if an operator makes
an error in this there could be
consequences
which could lead to an accident as well
after speaking on the phone with french
president emmanuel macron it appears
vladimir putin is willing to let
international inspectors access the
plant but the terms of annie visit are
still contentious redmond shannon global
news london
people in moscow flock to the grand
opening of russia's newest coffee chain
one that looks eerily familiar to a
north american staple nope that's not a
spelling mistake star's coffee
officially opened its doors in moscow
with an uncanny resemblance to giant
coffee chain starbucks which withdrew
from russia after the invasion of
ukraine the operators of stars are
vowing to reopen all russia's former
starbucks locations under this new brand
emerging high and dry ahead the
surprising bonus of a brutal drought
more than one thousand people have been
forced from their homes in the path of a
huge fast-moving wildfire near valencia
spain more than 400 firefighters and
dozens of helicopters and planes are
working around the clock to save
villages in the path of the fire while
the flames are being whipped up by
strong wind gusts the altura fire has
consumed more than 190 square kilometers
of forest and brush in the past few days
so far this summer nearly 3 000 square
kilometers of the spanish countryside
has been burnt
one unexpected side effect of king
spain's worst drought in decades has
delighted archaeologists the
re-emergence of a prehistoric stone
circle dubbed the spanish stonehenge the
circle of dozens of standing stones is
believed to date back to 5000 bc the
circle has been underwater since the
construction of a nearby dam in 1963 and
archaeologists are now racing to study
the ancient monument with modern tools
and techniques before it submerged again
the chinese government has issued a
national drought alert as the severe
heat wave still has the country in its
grip
the heat wave with temperatures into the
high 30s and low 40s has now lasted more
than two months and it's expected to
stick around until september rainfall
has been less than half of normal more
than 60 rivers have now dried up and
much of this year's harvest is now
wilting in the heat
military disaster next remembering
canada's bloodiest battle of the second
world war
80 years ago today more than 900
canadian soldiers were killed in the
raid of dieppe france in the second
world war
ceremonies across canada marked the
anniversary of operation jubilee
a ceremony at toronto's old city hall
honored the lives of those lost when
canadian soldiers were sent onto the
german occupied beaches in 1942
a small number of veterans who served
that day remain and as eric sorensen
reports one in particular made the trip
back to dieppe for the occasion
somewhere on this beach at dieppe was a
canadian soldier gordon fennell he was
there amid the carnage and just 20 years
old
on the 80th anniversary of the attack he
is now 100 a member of the calgary tanks
who made it out alive
frail and old but determined to salute
those who died so young they shall
grow now old that we are left to grow
old
a moving recital of the act of
remembrance familiar still poignant
words at the going down with the sun and
in the morning
we will remember them we will remember
them from that tragic day
a raid that was supposed to catch the
nazis unprepared was a debacle for the
allies 900 canadians were killed in just
six hours
many more wounded or taken prisoner the
worst single day for this country in
world war ii there's a sting to it to
diep that will
canadians will never get past and
justifiably so and it is a legacy that's
really penetrated every part of canadian
psyche in every part of canadian
military history thirty years ago many
canadian veterans of dieppe were young
enough to journey by boat to the beaches
they had stormed a half century before a
lot of emotion a lot of good men were
lost there
ten years ago fewer in number still with
vivid memories of the friends they lost
he had a
fiancee
back home
in ottawa and now so few who can recall
dieppe firsthand the courage of our
heroes of the past
may their example inspire us in our life
of every day the french have always been
generous and solemn their gratitude
towards soldiers from so far away has
never diminished
to remember the terrible combat at
dieppe said france's secretary of state
for veterans the soldiers will not be
forgotten nor their families nor their
graves nor their flags
the ceremony has changed over time the
inclusion of indigenous people an
important part of canadian history often
overlooked decades ago
the anniversary is commemorated every
year but the graves nearby with canadian
symbols and names are a reminder every
day of what happened here
eric sorenson global news
and that is global national for this
friday night i'm farah nasser on behalf
of our whole team here at global
national i want to thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
nito garcia will be at the anchor desk
this weekend also this weekend the
canadian national exhibition also known
as the x returns to toronto after a
two-year pandemic hiatus
[Applause]
for the adventurous ketchup and mustard
ice cream are on the menu and after a
scaled-down version last year
vancouver's pacific national exhibition
or the pne is back in full force
starting tomorrow i'll see you again on
monday until then take care of
yourselves and each other have a
wonderful weekend good night
[Music]
you